[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight it's not a partisan
talking point or really any kind of
exaggeration at
all to say that joe biden has opened
this country's borders to the world
since biden's inauguration in january
the border patrol has apprehended close
to a million foreign nationals coming
into this country overland through
mexico
how many people is that well it's more
people than live in the entire cities of
san francisco
or denver or seattle or indianapolis or
boston or charlotte we could keep going
and that's all in just six months that
is enough people to change this country
forever
you may argue that's a good thing
america will benefit from this mass
influx of new people from foreign
countries
if so we'd love to hear that argument in
detail no one so far has explained how
that works
but what you can't argue is that opening
the borders was legal
or that anyone in this country voted for
it
the current mass movement of foreign
nationals into the united states was
never
approved by congress no one passed a law
demanding it
the buy administration just did it
unilaterally without asking americans
what they thought of it
they probably already knew every poll
we've ever seen shows clearly that
voters of all backgrounds
oppose open borders that policy is
highly unpopular
so the administration couldn't say out
loud what they were doing instead they
operated in secrecy they hid it
they're hiding it right now so what
exactly are they doing
tonight we have new information for you
that answers that question at least in
part
this show has confirmed that the biden
administration has enlisted the u.s
military to move illegal immigrants
secretly around
our country that is happening at lachlan
air force base in texas
we know it's happening there because a
man called lieutenant colonel matthew
burroughs sent his subordinates an email
spelling it out very clearly
quote over the next few days weeks or
months the note began you may see
passenger aircraft on our ramp
transporting undocumented non-citizens
please review the attached public
affairs guidance on the issue
barros's email then instructed uniformed
military personnel to hide
what was happening on the base from the
country
they're sworn to serve quote do not take
photographs
and refrain from posting anything on
social media
now lieutenant colonel burroughs offered
no national security justification for
keeping any of this secret because there
is no national security justification
for keeping it from the rest of us he
just told the people who worked for him
not to talk now we got his email from a
whistleblower and at first we doubted it
could be real
during the last administration you'll
remember the pentagon firmly refused to
protect america's southern border that's
not our job they said it's too political
send us to syria and yet according to
this document here was the very
same u.s military leadership at the
pentagon
helping the biden administration with
maximum
enforced stealth with secrecy to subvert
this country's core immigration laws
it was hard to believe that could be
happening but it is happening
the pentagon has confirmed it to us
spokesman chris mitchell described the
flights from lachlan as
non-citizen movement part of what he
called the u.s
immigration and custom enforcement's
mission he told us then to direct any
further questions to ice
so we did we called ice multiple times
ice did not deny they were using lachlan
air force base to relocate large numbers
of foreign nationals into the interior
of our country
and do it secretly the question is where
are all these people going
several times ice promised us additional
details but in the end we never heard
back
apparently americans do not have a right
to know where foreign nationals are
being resettled in their own country
we do know thanks to the center for
immigration studies that the
administration the bite administration
has been sending illegal migrants all
over the united states for some time now
watch this what's happening most of the
time is that they are boarding buses
and heading into america's heartland a
conveyor belt of commercial
and charter buses just like this one in
del rio texas
are carrying tens of thousands sight
unseen
from texas arizona and california
borderlands
northward and they are dropping their
haitian venezuelan
cuban and central american family units
in florida and new jersey tennessee
massachusetts michigan north carolina
georgia kentucky
and to large cities in texas such as
dallas and houston
oh changing the electoral map are we
serving the businesses that paid for you
get elected are we yes we are
now those are buses you just saw now the
administration is using
aircraft and air force bases and that
ought to give you some sense of the
scale
involved here what you're watching is
demographic transformation
in our country without our consent and
in violation of
our laws that is happening now our job
is to shut up and accept it we know that
they will call us names
if we don't accept it but no thanks
what's happening what they're doing
is wrong it is moreover a violation of
the most
basic promise of democracy which is that
citizens get to control
who runs the government we as citizens
have an
absolute right to know what exactly they
are doing
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else